what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and yesterday was
sdcc and marvel fans were treated to an
amazing hall h panel by marvel studios
in which they revealed all of phase five
in a little bit of phase six including
the actual release date for the
fantastic four which is going to be
november 8th of 2024 and of course the
announcement of two new avengers films
the king dynasty coming out on may 2nd
of 2025 and then the same year avengers
secret wars on november 7th of 2025 but
one of the biggest things that we got
yesterday was the official teaser
trailer for black panther wakanda
forever and there is so much in this
trailer so much that i did not think
they were going to actually show us in
the teaser but it's probably one of the
best trailers that i've ever seen and
it's super emotional and in this video
i'll break down everything that you need
to know including the plot of the film
which is actually made pretty clear
based on what we see in the trailer and
based off of what we've heard so i'll be
explaining exactly what's going on here
of course we'll be talking about namor
the sub mariner the villain of this film
and mutants because he is a mutant in
the comics we'll also be talking about
the avengers vs x-men story dr doom and
how he could actually be behind
everything that we see in this trailer
some deaths that are foreshadowed and of
course wakanda versus atlantis and the
new black panther and if you're new to
the channel and you love marvel be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest videos so the trailer
opens up in a very and i've heard this
word used a lot in regards to this
trailer in a very somber way obviously
we have lost chadwick boseman who was a
complete legend he was battling cancer
but he kept it a secret from mostly
everybody that he knew including marvel
studios but still gave his all in every
one of his performances and you can
definitely feel him so much in this
trailer now this film is going to focus
on who the new ruler of wakanda is going
to be and who the next black panther
will be marvel said they're not
recasting t'challa but they never said
that there isn't going to be a new black
panther and obviously in the very last
scene of this trailer we do see a new
black panther however the question is
who exactly is this is it shuri is it
umbaku is it killmonger we'll talk about
that in a bit and of course this movie
will focus on the battle between neymar
his home atlantis and the atlanteans and
wakanda now the trailer opens with the
song no woman no cry by bob marley it
then transitions into all right by
kendrick lamar with the lyrics saying we
gon be all right kind of reflecting the
state of t'challa's family and wakanda
right now it opens with nakia looking
off into the water with a mayan or aztec
temple in the back now in the mcu namor
and the atlantean story is going to be
that they are descendants from an
ancient mayan or aztec family so a
little different than the comics nakia
is right off the coast and the temple is
right off the water as well reflecting
on what's to come which is going to be a
battle between the atlanteans who live
in the water and the wakandans who of
course live on the land from here we see
queen ramonda who is on the throne now
because t'challa has passed away and he
is no longer the king of wakanda you can
tell that she's very emotional about
being on the throne because it's where
her husband once sat until he died in
captain america civil war and then her
son sat there after who of course has
recently passed away so it's clearly
very emotional for her to sit on this
throne now then it actually goes right
into the funeral of t'challa which
actually seems like it's more of a
celebration of t'challa rather than a
funeral we can see everybody is wearing
white clothes but separately we can see
that shuri and queen ramonda do wear
black clothes which are customary for
funerals as we see the funeral scene we
continue to hear the lyrics of bob
marley that say good friends we have and
good friends we've lost along the way
obviously reflecting on king t'challa
but also chadwick boseman himself now we
see that the entire kingdom of course
has obviously been severely affected by
the death of t'challa and we can see
that everybody is mourning queen
raimonda shuri the dora milaje and then
we actually see the birth of neymar the
submariner now in the comics name more
is considered the first mutant which is
true to the order in which the character
appeared in print in the comics and
marvel themselves typically refer to
neymar as the first mutant and i'm
hoping the mcu keeps this the same and
it looks like they might actually do
that because in miss marvel they did
reveal that kamala khan is indeed a
mutant so mutants have been introduced
into the mcu and in the comics namor is
a mutant half mutant hopefully they
stick true to that in this film and it
looks like they actually are because if
you take a look at baby namor's ankles
you can actually see little wings on
them this is taken right from the comics
neymar has wings on his feet that give
him the ability to fly later on in the
comics professor xavier would find him
and tell him that he is indeed a mutant
however of course keep in mind that the
mcu often changes origins and powers but
we cut from baby namor being born to a
full-grown neymar who we see wearing a
headdress and if you look closely it
actually seems to be the head of some
type of sea serpent now this could be a
reflection of the atlantean god who may
be responsible for giving neymar some of
his powers in the mcu much like the
black panther god bast gives powers to
black panther with the heart-shaped herb
gods are becoming a big part of the mcu
we have the asgardian gods of course
thor love and thunder actually
introduced the greek gods and we did
actually see bass in thor love and
thunder at omnipotent city and of course
moon knight introduced the egyptian gods
so i wouldn't be surprised if the
atlanteans had their own god and even in
one scene we can actually see neymar
looking at some type of an ancient mural
that does have some type of an ancient
dragon or sea serpent on it so he could
be getting part of his powers from this
god in the comics he does have the
ability to fly because he is a mutant so
he's only half atlantean his mother who
was atlantean had him with a human or a
mutant because the mutant side is on his
dad's side this is why neymar has the
ability of a mutant but can also breathe
underwater since he is half atlantean
but this is also why he doesn't have
blue skin like the rest of the
atlanteans because he's only half we see
atlanteans using whales as
transportation and then from here it
seems like the plot is made pretty clear
for the most part if we combine what
we've seen with what we've heard and we
have a lot more to talk about but first
a big thank you to athletic greens for
sponsoring this video if you are trying
to be more healthy if you're trying to
support your immune health if you're
looking to have more energy and you're
tired of taking all of those pills
athletic greens is for you i wanted to
see what all of the hype was about so i
tried athletic greens it gives you over
75 high quality vitamins minerals
adaptogens and probiotics now this is
lifestyle friendly so you can take this
whether you're doing paleo keto vegan
dairy-free gluten-free you can still
take this and it's less than three
dollars a day which is pretty cheap
considering you're investing in your
health and the best part is it actually
tastes pretty dang good so if you're
looking to get healthier and toss out
the pills and the supplements athletic
greens makes it easy they're going to
give you a free one year supply of
immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
cosmic again that is athleticgreens.com
cosmic take ownership over your health
and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance now remember the
last black panther movie ended with
t'challa addressed in the united nations
telling them that they are going to
finally open up their resources to the
rest of the world now of course the rest
of the world had no idea what wakanda
actually was they thought it was a third
world country having no idea that
wakanda was actually the richest country
in the world and the most
technologically advanced because of
their vibranium so we cut to the scene
which takes place on a ship where it
looks like people are going to be diving
deep deep into the ocean and this is
most likely the cause of neymar going at
war with wakanda these people are most
likely diving for vibranium trying to
find it in the ocean in which case
they're going to get a little bit too
close to neymar and atlantis and this is
what is going to lead to some major
conflict wakanda is the one who opened
up their doors and resources to the rest
of the world exposing that they had
vibranium which means that neymar is
probably going to view wakanda as the
reason that all of this is happening
he's going to view it as their fault we
also have a scene of neymar when he is
younger he's at the surface with some
atlanteans surrounding him and if you
look closely the atlanteans actually
have to use masks as breathing
apparatuses on their face because they
are true atlanteans they breathe
underwater not above water so they
require these breathing devices but
namor being only half atlantean and half
human slash mutant can breathe above
water but young neymar is standing in
front of a house that is on fire it then
immediately cuts to him being an adult
walking out of the water to the shores
of wakanda so i'm thinking there's a lot
more to namor's backstory with wakanda
and what i believe is his parents the
scene where that house is on fire could
be the death of not only his father but
maybe also his mother as well and
perhaps namor thinks that it was
wakanda's fault or wakanda's doing that
his father and or mother died this could
be the reason that the hate for
wakandans is actually placed in neymar's
heart way before the events of black
panther wakanda forever now in this
scene we know that he is arriving at
wakanda when he steps out of the water
because several scenes later some
wakandans and imbaku actually attack him
on the surface the atlanteans beside him
dive into the water but namor isn't even
phased and he just stands there this is
probably because he is considerably more
powerful than the other atlanteans due
to him being part mutant now umbaku
attacks him but probably isn't going to
be enough to defeat him on his own it's
probably going to come down to shuri
taking the heart-shaped herb now we know
from a black panther wakanda forever
tie-in book that shuri actually does
manage to recreate the heart-shaped herb
so it is most likely her who becomes the
next black panther although there might
be more than one now in the comics shuri
does become black panther at one point
in time as she grows up she always wants
to be black panther but her brother
becomes black panther however t'challa
does see the potential in his sister so
he trains her and eventually in the
comics when t'challa was put in a coma
by the attacks from doctor doom shuri
actually does become black panther
however when she first takes the
heart-shaped herb and sees the black
panther god bast she is actually denied
the powers of black panther at first
it's only later on that she goes to
prove herself that she is given the
powers now we see shuri in the throne
room and everything seems to be on fire
this could be when she takes the
heart-shaped herb now something that is
really really interesting that i think
marvel might actually be tricking us
with is what queen ramonda says she says
i am queen of the most powerful nation
in the world but then she says and my
entire family is gone have i not given
everything now the fact that she says
entire family actually implies that
shuri is gone as well so does shuri die
in black panther wakanda forever i don't
believe so i don't think that shuri dies
in wakanda forever i do think that she's
going to be one of the new black
panthers and i do think that there
should be two we'll get to that in a bit
because i actually think queen raimondo
might die in the trailer we can see the
throne room and wakanda is actually
being flooded by namor this is actually
taken right from the comics in the
avengers vs x-men story where namor
floods wakanda and if i had to guess i
would guess that queen raimonda probably
doesn't make it out of the flood alive
this will be really big if it does
happen because this movie is already
going to be dealing with the death of
t'challa so adding another death is
pretty big but of course the mcu has to
move forward and things have to be set
up and what this could do is make it to
where imbaku could actually be king and
even the next black panther but i think
this dialogue that queen raimonda is
speaking here is actually a big
misdirect i actually think that it could
be shuri that is saying this they simply
had her voice this for the trailer to
throw us off because this is just a
little too obvious for me they would not
reveal that shuri is going to die in the
very first teaser trailer for wakanda
forever but i'm guessing that this
dialogue is still in the movie but
probably comes from shuri now we also
have iron heart in this movie as well
she is in wakanda and we know that she's
going to have her very first iron heart
suit and we even have a scene of riri
williams aka iron heart where it looks
like she is making her first suit and
this scene very much mirrors the scene
where tony stark is making his very
first iron man suit with the hammer in
the cave and riri williams cuts out a
metal heart which of course represents
her character iron heart now during this
trailer we see some soldiers board the
ship and the soldiers aren't with the
atlanteans and they are not with the
wakandans so the big question is who
exactly are they with and here's where i
think doctor doom comes into play i
think what we're seeing here is kind of
a play on the doom war story and doctor
doom is going to be looking for
vibranium doctor doom has been rumored
for wakanda forever for such a long time
now and although this is not confirmed
by any means there have been a lot of
reports that state doom is coming to the
mcu sooner rather than later and this
would fit quite perfectly if doctor doom
was indeed behind what is happening in
wakanda forever because although namor
is the villain of this movie namor isn't
really a true villain he's more of an
anti-hero in the comics he is fought
with the avengers with the illuminati
with the fantastic four with the x-men
he's a good guy he just kind of has a
short temper but in the mcu he can't be
a true villain he is eventually going to
be somewhat of a hero and i think it's
going to be revealed that doom has
probably planted something in his mind
that made him go after wakanda or
tricked him in some way where it was his
soldiers and his people probably mining
for vibranium they could have made him
think that it was actually the wakandans
or other people of the world who were
there because wakanda revealed that
vibranium exists now at the end of this
trailer it shows neymar taking his spot
on his throne in atlantis and it looks
like this might be where he is declaring
war upon wakanda because the next few
scenes are wakandans going at war with
atlanteans and the very final scene is
of a new black panther fighting namor if
you take a look in the background you
can see that that person in the back is
indeed namor now as far as who the new
black panther could be i'm assuming that
it is probably shuri although this black
panther suit does have a lot of gold in
it really reflecting killmonger's black
panther suit now it is a possibility
that killmonger could return in moon
knight they showed us that people can
actually come back and they did even
mention the ancestral plane in moon
knight and i personally think that this
would be a really great route to go down
bring killmonger back bring him back as
a true good guy and bring back michael b
jordan however in the first black
panther movie t'challa is looking at the
suits that shuri made him and he does
say that the gold is a little bit too
much however it is more of shari's style
so this could be shuri here as far as
embaku is concerned i think this figure
that we see here is probably too small
to be embaku winston duke is a pretty
big guy and this person's frame here
seems to be a lot smaller so i'm
guessing it's probably shuri now at the
end of the day they always could have
two black panthers they could have shuri
but then they could have another male
black panther because black panther is a
very important character to a lot of
people in real life and rumor has it
that nakia is actually pregnant with
t'challa's baby and this baby could
eventually go on in the mcu to be our
true black panther who knows he could
even start off being a part of the young
avengers then eventually go on to be the
true king of wakanda but if you have any
great theories about this let me know in
the comments down below and let me know
your overall thoughts about this black
panther wakanda forever teaser trailer i
thought it was fantastic i thought the
music was amazing and this is probably
one of the best trailers for marvel
studios there is let me know your
thoughts down below don't forget to like
the video and of course subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
marvel videos for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof
you